did you guys just wake up welcome to
rydell a good morning I'm so excited
this is one of my absolute favorite
podcasts please put your hands together
for the dollop he gave it a world in
jamero hi everybody hi I'm I'm the
dollop that's definitely tough to hear
straight what is going on what yeah
you're really saving that little
chestnut huh
how sad is it that I came down here
before the show and put that back there
oh that wasn't oh you had it like a
setup and then you're basically
carrot-top your girl top I am girl top
you guys know what I'm talking about
don't create I hear a beeping yeah
someone's watches the someone has
somewhere to be and we go to the dollop
right now and their alarm is good so I'm
backing up who's backing up is it what
pop it's the popcorn machine you know
it's a really it's a great show when you
can hear the popcorn machine well we we
can tell you're locked in what's that
beeping a mile and a half away there's a
beeping is that what is that on a
mountaintop a goat is shrilling what do
we shut it down okay that guy's honking
his goddamn horn stop shutting doors
okay um I wish I could remember the
[ __ ] guy's name so we have a we have
in the audience is they how many people
have never heard the podcast before okay
see we're doing good clapping a hand
raised so we weren't clear but there you
know some hands went up and others claps
so could you could you just blink
so in the audience is a direct
descendent of Samuel Whitmore oh [ __ ]
how about that [ __ ] that's real [ __ ] do
you remember who that is
yeah there's no idea who that is I know
I know the badass old guy yeah the old
guy from the Revolutionary War and sir
I'll just say big fan so wherever you
are we want to thank our subscribers at
patreon you guys are awesome
that's not directed to the hand-raisers
I think if same thing to say it sounded
normal when you said it but because it
we just we just do this for money no
okay don't we don't have fun don't open
up anymore put the hat back on that bit
that was a better [ __ ] variable nope
it's a tedious arduous [ __ ] pot buddy
that tastes my soul Dave oh wait all
right pal and my wife doesn't love me
anymore cuz she doesn't see me my son
calls me Phil yeah it must be tough to
have your name change like that Wow well
hey this Kitty has claws I think we need
to borrow Merrill from shows his name's
marble marble just changed ladies and
gentlemen
originally we had Patton Oswalt lined up
but he is a [ __ ] [ __ ] and so we
got somebody better much better not as
popular
what's happening but better better in a
way that he's funnier Dave and smart
smarter but just not to the masses not
he was on a show that was canceled on
TBS I think Rory I don't and he is
I believe available for work ladies and
gentlemen Rory Scovel he was we made him
wait outside way to kick it off right
for me bring me up with some pizazz
folks here's who we wanted here's who we
ended up with I'm happy oh but there
were others they were we tried to get
patton oswalt and ten other people and
then Rory was actually just standing
outside a few minutes ago and you were
selling stuff from your tote bag I was
trying to sell some of the free stuff we
got and Dave was like do you want to be
on our podcast and I said you got it so
I'm here to lend my services I'm not hot
but I will take this off if I become hot
yeah you will I like how you work hey
Rory
hey Rory
yeah hey November 18 1962 let us go
there jamesy sullivan was born in New
York City the son of Irish immigrants
perfect true thank you for doing all the
reasons I'm unaware that it's not a game
show true I I think true right no please
hit your buzzer buzzer if you think
that's a fact I have a cold so I'll be
coughing like I'm dying throughout this
podcast
his parents are working-class and he got
a public education at 16 he started
working at Frank Lesley's publications
you guys remember that yeah Frank Leslie
and two years later he started his own
paper the athletics news okay he
continued to work in sports publishing
and expanded into selling sporting goods
so far pretty boring yeah I mean that's
what we're all thinking but those were
glory days that's a glory time yeah just
call your newspaper exactly athletic
news like no creativity we're the
athletic news any questions he was an
athlete himself starting his run at 15
as a member of the pastime Athletic Club
that's a great name too and in 1888 he
helped establish the Amateur Athletic
Union which was created to establish
common standards for amateur sports huh
yeah I make so amateur sports were not
really regulated before then so right
you could do anything they were like no
oh no touchdown piss on him what I feel
like that might not have been now a oh
you are hot oh boy you know after my
after my athletic news joke didn't hit I
thought do you know how to take off a
jacket yeah usually people will will the
flopping one arm there's that moment
when you're taking your jacket up the
only way out is through so Sullivan he's
in the Amateur Athletic Union to create
common standards for amateur sports
wrestled control from the other amateur
athletic unions in the country and he
was exactly the kind of [ __ ] that was
needed to fight for control quote he was
blunt avoided compromise and preferred
honest directness no matter who got hurt
okay
so right so he didn't mind what happened
he would just
get his way yeah he's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
well alright maybe he's a visionary he
as big break came in 1890 when he was
asked to run the American a sports
publishing company he uses power in that
position to push the AAU and it's and
his agenda and under his control the a
you took over and soon most US national
championships took place under its
leadership he wanted to show above all
the supremacy of him the American
athlete yep hmm that's a little bit of a
red flag you think yeah the athlete will
reigning race only athletes will control
the world that was probably his voice go
on so he just wanted to make sure the
amateur athletes in the states were the
best well he wanted to show that the
American athlete was better than
everybody else and you're very emphatic
so when you say better than everyone
else do you mean better than athletes
from other countries or just people in
general actually every much your athlete
is the best you can do just everybody
just don't tell them about professional
you guys are doing great
no we didn't sell any tickets tonight
you don't need to you're at the height
of your career the pinnacle you're not
doing it for money back in the weight
room you amateurs now in 1904 the city
of st. Louis was planning to host an
event called the Louisiana Purchase
Centennial Exhibition catchy
alright the SLE P whatever you say what
why wouldn't you celebrate 100 years of
buying did something with it so it was
actually combined and turn into a
World's Fair the Louisiana Purchase
occurred in 1803 but 1904 is a hundred
and one years later you're doing the
math well but the planning you really
want to make sure you do it right so you
start planning on the anniversary for a
big shindig right a year from then yes
it was delayed to allow for larger
participation of more states in foreign
countries there be exhibitions from
t-62 foreign countries on the 43 states
big big hoo-ha six did you see 6262
foreign countries 43 states really old
worlds why all this is going on the
International Olympic Committee was
looking at different US cities to hold
the Olympics in in 1904 and after
contemplating New York and Philadelphia
they awarded the Olympic Games to
Chicago this would be the third Olympic
Games but the city of st. Louis was not
pleased the Olympics were going to take
place at the same time as the Louisiana
Purchase centennial plus one year
exhibition horror ambience - this story
really the exact same weekend great beer
and now I'm worried I didn't expect
misinterpreting the story so Louie's
gonna do what any respectful City would
to do they decide to hold their own
sports competition and they reached out
to Sullivan and of course Sullivan
agreed to stage the AAU Track and Field
Championships at the World's Fair the
Amateur Athletic Union was huge so this
was a big deal and a big problem for the
Chicago Olympics what they were trying
to do was to force the IOC to move the
games to st. Louis having a larger
competing athletic event happening at
the same time as the Olympic Games could
spell ruin so Olympics founder Pierre de
Coubertin
gave in yeah yes he's French you know I
looked it up I [ __ ] went and I
pressed a button and a french guy went
via there couple thing and I was like I
got I got this mmm Pierre the scent was
strong
someone get Pierre on the phone
yeah we found another body was it an
amateur or a professional athlete we're
not talking about professionals so
Pierre gave in and the games were
switched to st. Louis but Pierre was
pissed of course he said he said he
thought quote the Olympiad would match
the mediocrity of the town of st. Louis
that's backhanded have fun
I love might be front handed I love a
calm comment like that really puts the
st. Louis in their place now you've
always hated saintly always hated him no
matter what it's just that's all I've
got
sorry chapter two once the decision was
made appear pretty much bowed out of the
Olympics all communication between st.
Louis and ku Bertini stopped he actually
loathes loathe Sullivan so Sullivan st.
Louis were on their own to do what they
wanted so they were making their own
Olympics there was no Olympic Charter
for them to follow no rules they know
nothing wait a rulest Olympics yep
that's the year poker got in poker slid
right under the door we've always been
in the Olympics yeah a cop here he's not
answering
yes yep the World's Fair was much longer
than the Olympic Games instead of
lasting two weeks the Olympic Games were
incorporated into the fair which meant
they would take place over seven months
right what no that's strange countries
what is their hotel bill I'll say
goodbye to your wife and kid they'll be
here holder what do you see him again
so they did not only did they have no
affiliation with the Olympic Committee
anymore but they had no idea what the
Olympics were zero idea of the timeframe
what do you think seven months for this
guy seven eight how long does it take to
do this seven if we're rushing all right
let's rush do seven okay the April to
November and the rest of the world
wasn't as into the Olympics in a
second-tier US city that would be
difficult to travel to and would take
place for seven months so many nations
decided not to go to the 1904 Olympic
Games yep
the fair / Olympics start on April 30th
1904 the opening ceremony for the
Olympics was four and a half months milk
it were still building the opening
ceremony was held in May after many
speeches from a lot of politicians track
and field
contests immediately commenced
spectators watched the event in the
packed stadium but what they were
actually watching were the Missouri high
school track and field championships I
don't even understand what I'm not gonna
lie they turned out for this one huh
your discovery of this story is a
screenplay ready to be written hope no
one here write screenplays the fair
itself was nothing like anyone had ever
seen it was the largest wait sorry why
why were they watching high school
people what happened
they just how were they gonna feel 7
months with [ __ ] athletes they're
just like yeah alright so they so the
opening ceremony was was a scam they
just insane
think about it's a little bit of both
parent a packed stadium a packed stadium
with all the earthís to compete in the
Olympics I just thought this was the
1500 honey what's it say on the ticket
this is the make-a-wish stage it says
who's that down there do that others
know it's regular kid looks like he's 13
he is 13 oh yeah it's the best athlete
and the
world support team and a little chubby
it was the largest largest exposition
that had ever been held covering 1272
acres the fair had educational exhibits
including scientific agriculture art
great inventions and discoveries health
quote electricity up to 1904 thank God
they didn't get into the 1906
electricity and 1904 Jesus Christ what
would happen we'll have to plug
ourselves in I'm picturing a coach in
the locker room going guys I'm not going
to lie to you these people think this is
so seriously try to behave please when
you're out there you're competing for
the gold or a medal that everyone gets
there is also machinery manufacturing
mining quote new hat new household
methods benefit it's a great well it's
also a fair it's a fair slash Olympics
it's and then there's women's progress
since the World's Fair at Chicago which
is probably great great exhibition
they're wearing dresses still zero
progress for women I'm wondering what
was the amount of progress they were
allowed to like an empty room where they
just assumed nobody would go like
someone tried to go in there like sir
you put why you push that door buddy
women's progress now that you know
there's something about electricity in
1906 we'll hit that up to go down there
watch some of the world's best teenagers
compete I feel like if they went in
there was just a woman churning butter
goddamn gun shut the door anyway don't
go in there and tell everyone else to
not go in there
photographers came with their bulky
cameras one of those who tuggers was
Jesse Tarbox Beals from Buffalo
she was the nation's first female news
photographer when she left
Buffalo newspapers reported that quote
Buffalo lost one of its best
professional women today but when she
applied for an official pat press pass
at the fair she was denied fair
officials didn't think she could do what
men did hauling a camera all over the
grounds Jesse contacted the local papers
hoping to get hired as a staff
photographer nope they all turned her
down so she went back to the fair
officials with more ammo in the form of
all of her past work and totally wore
them down
I hope on her way she passed the women's
progress exhibit stopped it was just
like you can live in here I guess no
that's not what I want
also I love the Buffalo was like well
she's not coming back
she's going to report she's not we've
been here before
good lord lost another one they don't
come back no st. Louis will be amazing
compared to Buffalo that's the that's
the self esteem of Buffalo when she gets
to st. Louis there's fun in the world
bright lights of st. Louis look out
coming back goodbye now well you got a
chance it gets the hustle and bustle oh
that's a Lewis life just the energy in
the life of st. Louis Lewis is the town
barely maps have fun being awake for
seven months
reporting seven-month olympics carrying
that bulky camera she took all their
life's work the next day after she was
hired a headline in the local st. Louis
newspaper read quote woman gets permit
to take pictures at the fair watch it
honey get in here
have you seen today's paper get the kids
and my gun
we're moving to Buffalo I hear they're
kicking their female photographers out
of town Jesus Christ the god damn
apocalypse anyway she went on to take
pretty much the best photos of the fair
surprise she photographed exhibits like
the world's largest organ the world's
largest cedar bucket weight or actual
organ not I want anything not it wasn't
like a liver that wasn't somebody you
know what I like when you say that she
like took the best pictures you know
that if they were making a movie about
her they would include the character who
existed in real life of the man who
would look at regular pictures like
compared to the others they're like
blurry and shitty like cuz she's in
focus what does that even mean to you
Jason
who cares squit your eyes your lazy
pieces I'm not trying to look at the
athlete that's a high-school kid I want
to see the horizon I know they're in
focus but she's a woman how could I
possibly love this photograph more than
this other photograph I mean good lord
person I tricked you this bird both her
photographs god damn it fine you're the
worst assistant write an article about
it fizzled out quick all right
she also photographed the world's large
largest cedar bucket and never mind now
I'm off her team now by the way that's
in Tennessee today if you want how big
is it it's six feet that's a big-ass
bucket I was a superuser cold metal
bucket yeah bucket want a medal what are
we gonna do with it
what put the organ in it throw that
liver in there drown the woman no no no
no no no more spitballing there'll be no
more spitballing took a dark turn early
no more brainstorming they're all so
crazy new food items like cotton candy
peanut butter dr. pepper puffed wheat
cereal and waffle cones
okay so not a bad night yeah we still
use those things today yes there was
beautiful Jim key of famous performing
horse oh you don't need to tell us who
that horses Jim key Jim key what a pony
yes is it J I am space K ey j IM like ki
or it's actually jim key gym key like
the name of a person yes beautiful jim
key so his first name is beautiful
middle name Jim last name key not a lot
of people have that name now they're out
there name beautiful Jim Kia true his
owner said he could read and write about
to jump in mmm so they're so this is not
only a beautiful yes horse with a man
named yes but it's also literate very
little yes you I can also read and write
and babysit children yes and it could
fly and it just wrote an article about a
woman photography and what else can it
do well it's a field goal kicker it can
make change you can also make change
just let's just see the newspaper giant
headline horse can read and write
honey come in here Jesus Christ the
world is insane oh my god what's real
anymore is a horse that can read and
write shut up Rebecca sorry should
you're right
I'll be in the churning of course the
horse can read and write it's the woman
and the snapping of the photo I believe
a woman can manipulate a camera but of
course the horse can read and write and
make change he's a horse
it's beautiful Jim key he owes me $50 if
this photographer woman ever rides this
literate horse time travel will happen
fly through a Stargate into the sky
beautiful gym key can also do arithmetic
for numbers below 30 how was that even
possible how is it not possible as well
as sight Bible passages quote where a
horse is mentioned so he's like I'm only
doing the ones about horses just really
interest me anyway here's your change
but ha I mean the horse did someone
forced the horse passages on him he
didn't he didn't decide that it was like
the horse read the whole Bible and say I
only when I'm remember the ones with
horses in it what kind of behavior was
trying to make a point was this a fair
or a circus what was this well what was
the difference back then I now you're
learning now that I think about I don't
know all right so that's just your
normal fair crap right yeah and because
it was 1904 things got weird things then
one of the main attractions was the
Philippine village probably there a lot
of assumptions where this is going like
somewhere just like just like the State
Fair in Sacramento and immediately the
theater exploded with white guilt here's
where we go on read it their visitors
could gaze upon actual Filipinos living
in their native habitat in what put
weight yep now now were they did they
want to live in their habitat or where
they like polar bears in the zoo they're
like please free us and they're like
look adorable I love your accent I think
I think we all know the answer to that
question pretty certain none of them
we're on display like an animal
absolutely they were from the agora
tribe
who were dog eaters oh well so people
would walk around watching Filipinos
eating dogs everybody good
were there any athletes competing well
get there there were other villages too
pygmies from Central Africa as Syrians
the Turks tons of people from all over
the world as well as American Indians
like the Apache great Native American
warrior Geronimo was on display living
his dream all of these people were
called savages good good good good
and these savages would do what no no no
this is all day but all the savages
would do it the exhibitions would just
live their lives like they would in
their homeland each day while people
stared at them it's just a good fair
just fun it's just a fun fair the goal
the fair was to show how amazingly
advanced the people of America were and
white people in general compared to the
rest of the non-white world this was all
marketed by the fairs and this is the
actual name Department of exploitation
so they knew so they weren't like hiding
it they're like look we get it
hi Jim key Department of exploitation my
god you're a talking horse yeah let me
do the talking sir how old are you you
if it's under 30 otherwise this
conversations gonna have to stop my head
won't you see I am a horse can I rode a
horse and wages how am i changing right
sorry change right sorry there you go so
it was the Department of exploitation
job to promote all these wonderful
exhibitions promote that's the term the
department of exploitation used James
Sullivan was made head of the fair's
Department of Physical Culture his
department was to show how great the
American style of athletic athletic ISM
was and that's what he believes Sullivan
thought white Anglo Americans were
superior
in brains and brawn and he was gonna use
the fair and Olympics to prove it
basically this was the racial
superiority World's Fair slash Olympics
slash anniversary of buying Louisiana
all right Louisiana's purchase right
don't forget about that forgot that that
was thrown in first you went to the head
of the fair's Department of Anthropology
is a [ __ ] weird lot of departments
almost like a university with and he
suggested they combine their efforts and
he won't he he want to call it the
Special Olympics the idea was to have
the savages tried to do the same
athletic feats as very trained very
skilled white athletes
basically he knows no discus basically
it was like little brain it was like
walking into an auto shop and pulling
out a mechanic and making him swim like
Michael Phelps the head of the
Department of Anthropology
agreed to combine their efforts because
it would give him data and help make a
name for him in the new field of
anthropology so it's a win for everybody
well sounds like it's a win for everyone
everyone's getting their time in the Sun
unfortunately it wasn't as easy as
sounded the so-called savages in their
exhibits were actually paid showman
they had agents and show producers now
right now I'm on break I'm on an equity
five don't even right now don't look at
me with the headdress off turn your kid
away I'm having a smoke break [ __ ]
also most of them didn't want anything
to do with solvents [ __ ] up
competition idea many of them thought
the idea of the Olympics was ridiculous
and others just wanted to be paid like
the a new of Japan who climbed trees and
their exhibition Sullivan wanted them to
climb trees in the Olympics in the
Olympic tree climbing competition the
[ __ ] what no all right look anything can
be a sport we're gonna go around the
room raise your hand and tell us what
you think should be a sport climbing
trees of course climbing it was already
on the board
if it's on the board don't repeat it
digging we need a hundred new sports
guys we have a lot I to go see yes
tag could be a good yes of course
opening can yeah great get that high on
the board that's gonna be in the opening
ceremonies can Oh buddy which is a month
and a half yeah why would the ANU of
Japan climb trees for free in a
competition when they got paid to do it
in their exhibition so maybes running
into some problem since some events were
quickly a no-go like the water polo
event everyone thought it sounded stupid
disagree there but the planning went on
the planning went on and while it did
the fare went about its business on June
5th there was a bull fight scheduled to
take place in an arena the arena had
been I'm sure you bring it up because it
was great it's gonna be good the arena
had been built specifically for the bull
fight by promoter Richard Norris he
called that the Norris amusement company
arena it seated 16,000 Norris signed 36
bull fighters to contracts but there was
a bigger problem both fighting was
illegal in the United States and
Missouri and their pressure from
religious and animal rights groups the
governor ordered anyone involved in
bullfighting arrested but Norris had
already sold 8,000 tickets for $1 each
well what the [ __ ] the event went on as
planned yep
smart first there was a horse show next
came a lacrosse was jim key in the horse
show he's doing one-nighters he was
working in the box office it's good get
out of here it's good to know that at
that time our country was very
protective of bulls but very adamant
that the savages have their own just
humans after the lacrosse demonstration
the crowd started getting irritated in
situation
that's right guys lacrosse is fun
classes need gold sorry I'm gonna catch
it look at that neck yeah throw to the
gold they don't count where I keep it
score what an exhibit where where are
the Bulls
yeah all right guys we know you I want
the Bulls there's just 24 minutes of
lacrosse
we're lacrosse were better than water
polo that you all voted out of this
festival so the crowd got irritated and
started booing they come to see the man
they've kind of seen a man kill
something and they wanted it now so the
announcer announced a bullfighter Don
Emmanuel cervera then a deputy stepped
out and told the announcer there would
be no bullfighting the cops took Norris
and other organizers into the arena
office to discuss the Civic Arena office
now come with us we got a new crew tiny
closets I have the lacrosse guys milk a
little more time they'll be back in a
minute
stretch stretch guys the spectators all
demanded refunds instead of getting
refund
refunds they were told to leave said it
didn't go over well they started
throwing rocks through the windows of an
arena office police tried to stop the
growing riot but there were too many
rock throwers and not enough policemen
someone tried to storm the office but
the cops held them back at gunpoint
the mob then went into the arena and
released three Bulls I would honestly
watch the Olympics if it was like this I
would go to this sure well it's weird
lacrosse lacrosse demonstration I'm an
but the Bulls were so emaciated they
didn't really do anything they just
stood there now the crowd thought the
whole thing was a scam
so they set the horses so they set the
hay in the bull pen on fire the entire
grandstand was built out of pine and tar
paper
Dave for those flammable items Hey
weights no kidding gas first yeah so it
went up pretty fast the arena burned
completely to the ground
two days later bullfighters severa and
another bull fighter named Carlton bass
got into a fight over the lack of pay
and bass killed cervera so at least
something died right yeah it's a bull
fight so and now we're on to June
actually July
what good go it's the first of two
gymnastic events took place young George
Iser took part he was a product of
German based gymnastic clubs were very
popular in Germany and moved to the
states in the late 1800s
now George had one normal leg and the
other was amputated below the knee what
happened I could no one helped me I
wanted to be an example so George had
one normal leg in the other was
amputated below the knee and there he
had a wooden prosthetic and it was a
gymnast yep that's weird even more
shocked by that than the horse with the
horse that can fly now I've heard
everything
so he was part of a gymnastics club in
st. Louis and so he got involved in the
games the first event called the
International turner's Championship in
July he didn't do so well he came in
10th in the all-around in 71st in a
second all around surprisingly he
finished last in the triathlon
apparently it's hard to sprint and do a
long jump with one leg it's awkward I
would love I mean they know they have
the Olympics with people with
prosthetics let's Jack a [ __ ] clunky
wooden leg yeah like that's an Olympics
just people running around like
trying to do stuff and they can't it's
tremendous here ok I know it's a weird
it's a weird dream
the Special Olympics or as they be
called anthropology days what we're held
on August 12th and 13th Sullivan
Sullivan invited scientists from all
over the world to witness the event a
local paper described it the unique
spectacle of men deliberately throwing
stones at one another
wait so were those guys rioting just
athletes so much more trained you stood
in that than the gymnastics I just
bronzed in a rock fight so things are
pretty good over here
a pretty bad gash see the other guys if
I could see I can't
my vision is very blurry the in expect
of men deliberately throwing stones at
one another will be one of the features
at the eff athletic meet to be held at
the stadium Thursday and Friday in which
all of the savage tribe now at the
World's Fair will compete scientists the
invitation will go anywhere we're
scientists get those good parts it's an
event where people throw rocks at each
other all right yes that's very
scientific what kind of rocks are they I
would love to go to the courts that's
what interests me I'm a man of science
the first day was the shotput the high
jump the long jump the mile and other
events one was throwing a baseball -
where - what like - what just throwing
it put together in their backyard
baseball they're like go throw that
you're like
but you don't know what to do you have
to be taught at a throw a base but
that's all just throw yeah all right
guys welcome to throw I think put stuff
like that back in I agree yeah I agree -
absolutely Olympics and everyone's seen
who can throw a baseball before this
embrace yes this is more my speed
dude throw really [ __ ] [ __ ] god he's
gotta win the golden baseball throwing
now here's the catch they did not take
any time to teach the participants what
to do they were given instruction
immediately before the event without an
interpreter so they weren't given
instruction well they were but just in a
different language than they knew okay
you guys understand
all right go out there and throw
baseballs and then rocks at each other
thanks for doing this guy's they were
also not allowed to practice at all not
once
that's cheating they had no idea what
the high jump was and so it basically
was not an event [ __ ] who told them
the hundred yard dash was anything but
since they all spoke different languages
it was total chaos just getting them
lined up then when the starting gun went
off most had no idea what in the [ __ ] it
was terrified some just froze others not
realizing it was a race just slowly
amble down the track come on guys that's
what you that's what you needed the
rabbit you needed the little rabbit that
goes around the track get that [ __ ]
thing go get him
the ones who did run didn't know what to
do when they got to the finish line most
of them would just stop at the tape
instead of running through it well yeah
they probably didn't want to rip it
they're like that's that makes perfect
sense yes it does so then a bit
essentially it was just a the
competition was to see who could go
through the ribbon yeah yeah who was
brave enough to go through a ribbon
and the scientists are just like
interested and this I actually can't
wait to take this data back to my home
country and compute it in some way in
four months
what no return flight that's interesting
the majority of participants would
realize what the event was after it was
over and then when asked to have another
go but they were denied because quote it
violated the research design and
invalidated the racial comparisons to
white athletes agreed this is very true
sure well that makes perfect sense once
they know how to do it I get it now I
know what it is can we shut up the event
is over you lost but the white guys are
doing great aren't they look at them the
best teenagers this goddamn woman taking
pictures is she still she's over there
don't even look at her a riser that's so
crazy I'm serious I didn't even know
what rack focus was until I showed you I
grabbed coffee belongs in that
butter-churning room they were all
listed in the all the participants were
listed in the official games report
based on what country they were from and
with their names though the Congolese
pygmy who had sharpened teeth was
described in the report only as cannibal
but the event went great according to
the press great fun for savages read the
headline in the LA Times I just I
couldn't it would be great to live in a
time where your headlines were this and
say I mean I know our headlines are
insane but that is like to pick up a
paper and be like oh look savages that
fight the Olympics the other day I just
love picturing like them going back to
their home country be like where did you
go and like you won't you won't even
believe what I'm about to tell you doc I
was Lois I was there for seven months it
was a competing incompetent I didn't
know who was in to throw rocks against
the bunch other non-white people I
thought I was
walking down a road and it was a race
they shot at me and they got pissed when
I didn't go through a ribbon never go to
America never was gorgeous this time of
year what day two was supposed to be
better Sullivan considered these events
to be more savage friendly sure there
was the tree climbing contest archery
fighting demonstrations a mohawk versus
Seneca lacrosse match and mud throwing
oh my god what how do you even
did I mention mud throw yeah throwing
it's the final thing on the list guys we
need I gotta go home my wife's although
we're not leaving till we have a flying
event how do we got what do we have that
we can use
we got baseball throw we got tree climb
we got count fast we got hey we got look
we got see the furthest Hey look at me I
believe me guys more mud
Jesus Christ I want to get back to the
person who can see the farthest I see a
lot of holes and I know we're rushing to
get out of here but that one to me I'm
worried about
I hope my miming to smoke a cigarette
translate totally well into the podcast
hole into the mic harder people can tell
people can tell why does he keep
breathing guys rewind and imagine me
smoking a cigarette during that little
act out we call state work okay they
also had a javelin contest because they
figure it was exactly like a spear and
every savage would know how to throw a
spear right there not to just throw it
far right well but now we know where
that came from
but it's not like everybody throws a
spear who's not white no I agree but
still like if you throw thing is you're
like give the savages Spears to compete
you might think they would use them as
web
perhaps wait are you saying that they
might turn on the audience I don't know
what I'm saying thank you thank you the
massacre and now the st. Louis massacre
but the fortunate thing was anthropology
days were put together so late that the
department of exploitation didn't have
time to properly promote it and the
result was that not many spectators
they're not gonna be able to exploit
them enough deadlines holy [ __ ] I got a
note before longer than a week out
please you're gonna be to do my thing
properly the great thing sorry I'm sorry
for that one no meat yeah
the great thing was is that each winner
of each contest well they didn't receive
a medal like a regular Olympics of
course they got something better I bet
they didn't a t-shirt the memories an
American flag Oh perfect yep perfect
take that back to your little mud hut
yep that ought to wipe the terrible
taste out of their mouths after this god
bless you guys James Sullivan saw the
event as a success he said it proved
enlighten Americans were the best
athletes in the world that the natives
were completely inferior he proved
savages couldn't play proper games or
participate in proper events like the
white man yep my god you should have
seen them trying to play tennis these
simple-minded idiots had no idea how to
play and score tennis it's like it's not
natural to them to understand tennis
like it is the white man who just
instinctively knows what to do on a
court they are foolish here's a racket
you'll know what to do and what those
lines mean look unless you're stupid
he double-faulted again Jesus he doesn't
even know how to serve
it's gone backhand for a reason stupid
he doesn't even know you can volley
don't keep playing once you serve maybe
rush the net play some defense oh my god
the ball oh we are so much better
we're the best play defense I hope we
never introduced soccer Sullivan said
quote the whole meeting proves that the
Savage has been a very much overrated
man from an athletic point of view who
would but who was like most athletic he
believed he had debunked the mythical
existence of the noble savage and in his
final report yes he wrote a report good
said lectures and authors will in the
future please donate all reference to
the natural athletic ability of savages
point made to all offers he said that
everybody knows oh this is we've done it
seven months where that guy talk about
holding a grudge oh we're just getting
started as a kid that he was like you
know what one day I'll show them I'll
put on a seven-month long fair and what
did you say over there
nothing I was just saying this coffee is
phenomenal where he's from thought I
heard something about savages and white
people oh why would I even say that I
want to make sure say do you know any
sports that people haven't heard of well
me and my friends used to always throw
mud at each other oh that's what's now
reported he had the weirdest creepiest
laughs it was so distracting for the
scientists they're trying to like write
stuff telling nobody make a joke nobody
make a joke yeah that's his real laughs
just ignore
the founder of the Olympic Games de Boer
Tom didn't go but was furious when he
heard about the Anthropology days he
believed that it was an outrageous
what's happening you guys alright he's
picturing himself laughing as the guy
more and more oh he's still oh he's
still there
distraction every time he introduces it
in that guy what he just said is so race
to your mouth God just let him do
whatever let him do anything just don't
make him laugh I'm shaking okay so now
it's time for the actual Olympic Games
what the sort of the official sort of
traditional period of livid games which
are held from August 29th through
September 3rd good lord
now how could a right now only 12
countries so so the whole so they're
calling everything the Olympic Games but
now they're doing the Olympic elope of
your days 45 days well they don't have a
lot of time so they just spent what that
is insane what are you talking about
they just spent months and months in the
Olympics making people climb trees and
throw rocks right and now there's gonna
they know what an actual Olympics is and
they're doing it Olympics within the
Olympics
no but someone else is running the
Olympics now they like real Olympics is
going to be double Olympics but not this
James dude isn't involved yes he is yeah
this is his locking Christ
this story yeah he's no he's totally
involved he's really having fun when he
gets started he doesn't stop is the
problem so now for these Olympic Games
only 12 countries had shown up okay so
as to st. Louis so of the 630 athletes
523 we're American
I like our chances yeah that's right
looks good to me over 50% of events were
between Americans well I like our
chances
including the tug-of-war contest shut up
oh yeah that we should have put that on
the list you want that one so it's more
of a field day than a day retreat it's
like a retreat out of the competing at
the ropes course later out of the
balance beam potato sack race the
three-legged race a water balloon my
apples
I got a spoon passing oranges between
our necks it's 3:00 three-legged race
three-legged race yeah what did I say I
don't know out of almost 100 sports of
the sports archery was the only event in
which women were allowed to compete
there were six women five from Ohio and
one of those who haven't won gold if you
can believe it
really they had one female exhibition
sport boxing interesting so women
couldn't participate in any sports
unless they were shooting arrows or
punching each other in the face shame we
changed that makes sense it was also not
the best run Olympics this one yep are
we talking about the same Olympics the
seven-month one yep it wasn't the best
run it was not huh what was the horse's
name of RAAM it
I'm Jim Jim Jim it's almost like Jim
Sullivan's laughing through as a horse
as this Olympics were gonna be having a
tug-of-war
Oh Hannes rung of germany finished fifth
in the 800 meters he was a favorite to
win but he got really tired in the later
part of the race the reason he got
really tired was because the day before
he had accidentally lined up and run in
the wrong race
so anybody could just read the 880 race
which he also didn't win because he was
an 800 runner before 40 race run
swimming then swimming venues were held
in open waters like rivers and lakes the
men's 50-yard freestyle race was held in
a man-made lake
zoltan homage of Hungary was maybe the
premier swimmer of the time he won the
race clearly defeating American J Scott
Leary by a foot but a US judge declared
the American the winner there we go this
led to a massive brawl between the
hungry and American swimming teams after
the fight was broken up they agreed to
race again homage won by a stroke there
was also an event called fancy diving
let's see where this goes this is where
it sounds quasi normal you just put on
your Sunday's best and that's your best
tuxedo what are you doing I'm diving
this afternoon all right this event was
popular in Germany and Sweden at the
time one would try to do elaborate
gymnastic feats in the air before
hitting the water
an American won the bronze medal but the
Germans protested they claimed the
German dives had been quote no fancy now
the ad the faster dives if you god
damned you judges we were diving very
fancy the whole time that was the
fanciest I've ever drove you can give
him the bronze but in my heart I have
the gold cuz I know how fancy we both
dived are there not one other diver was
able to hit the water and maintain the
top hat above the head
oh and look at this I still have my
monocle in blank yeah interesting
interesting how I wasn't gog ago the
Americans said they had better entries
into the water which the Germans didn't
seem to care about the Germans made
difficult fancy dives but then flopped
into the water on their stomachs I look
if you're looking for dad hasn't
finished maybe we're just not sateen
okay I stand corrected I maybe was not
the fanciest of diet gel we had the
waters old fanciest by far so fancy
while the Americans performed less
difficult but more graceful dives it was
suggested they have a dive off for third
place but german alfred von schweger
refused to participate I will not
participate horse manure
sorry Jim what's after 30 children
marriage and children thank you thank
you so much we got everyone listening at
home I got a standing ovation
if you stand when people clap I don't
think that counts
right is a standing ovation to some
degree that is what has cymatics but all
right in the boxing event a fighter
named Carol Burton entered as a
lightweight and won his first match
Burton was a very popular boxer in the
area but it was soon discovered he was
not Burton at all he was a man named
James Bollinger who assumed Burton's
identity what this is a goddamn
miniseries so many avenues of
storytelling going on here he did this
because Burton was popular and he wanted
to gain favor with the judges
so Bollinger was disqualified his next
opponent Peter
stur Holt got a bye to the semis then
Peter stur Holt was beaten by Jack Egan
Egan ended up with the silver and Peter
ster Holt got nothing for finishing
fourth but a year later they found out
Egan's name was not actually Jack Egan
he was Frank Floyd another posture so
Egan was stripped of the medal and a guy
named Van Horn moved up to silver and
Peter star hold won the bronze even
though he never won a fight she never
talks about the imposter era of boxing
big boxing right just to win a bra I
didn't do anything yeah you came in
third so I got beat once congratulation
gradually yeah good good for you well
done what's up yeah no I'm Mike Tyson
how are you yes I will fight yes I am
you know we're white white yep I am Mike
Tyson I'm Evander Holyfield they're
going to give the people what they've
wanted for a long time I love that this
original boxer was so popular that
people watched was he always Italian he
did a lot of work in the offseason it's
good on his face he's been completely
changed his face doing Italian sorry
now the Olympics big event was the
marathon this was the event that hearken
back to the days of Greece that tied the
ancient days to modern time but it's
gonna be a fitting tribute to be [ __ ]
great
some of the runners were legitimate
marathoners who had previous success and
other marathons most of the participants
were middle distance runners are just
weirdos the favourites we're Americans
Sam Miller al newton-john Lordan Michael
spring and Thomas Hicks these guys were
all experienced at marathons
there is also Fred lorz who trained at
night because he was a bricklayer during
the day he had landed a place in the
marathon by winning a five mile race
well that shot it that'll try to make
Center it makes sense bricklayer fans in
here now those were the legitimate
runners the contestants also included
ten Greeks who had never run a marathon
good
there was an ex mailman Cuban named
Felix Felix Carbajal he had raised money
to come to the US by running the length
of Cuba but when he got to New Orleans
he gambled on Tyson lost all his money
it's quite a siren that town then he had
to hitchhike to st. Louis there were two
mother guide Roe driving him didn't
believe anything he'd said to the
Olympics we go friend there were two men
of the SWANA tribe of South Africa who
were there as part of the boa war
exhibition the war it ended in 1902 what
war Boer War okay what happened I know I
got it yep thank you
the war ended in 1902 and when it was
over the British burned all the crops so
everyone living there was [ __ ] they
would take any job they could get and
the Boer War exhibition at the fair
which took place just two years after
the actual war ended was paying four
pounds a week the exhibition was created
by a captain who had fought for the
Rhodesian zhh
in the war men women and children signed
up at the fair they recreated two famous
battles of the war the battle
reenactments took two to three hours and
included several actual generals and 600
veteran soldiers from both sides of the
war oh my god
that's a really long event yeah bring
out lacrosse net on a stick in a tiny
bomb can't you get you guys but you can
throw it the farthest super short-shorts
mega tight come on guys it's really fun
the goalie stick is different [ __ ] the
two the two men entered the marathon
from South Africa had served as
messengers in the Boer War they had also
just participated in the one-mile event
and anthropology days in the actual war
they used to run great distances with
messages so they were considered to be
capable of winning the marathon they
just needed a message to be in their
hand right that's all
yep the marathon was twenty four point
eight five miles longer forty kilometres
it was Tuesday August 30th the
temperature was 32 Celsius 90 Fahrenheit
and it was to be run on a dusty unpaved
Road perfect the dust was said to be
inches thick good there were seven hills
and in one area crack stone was all over
the road which made it dangerous to run
or walk on the runners lined up at the
starting line the Kuban was wearing a
white long-sleeve shirt long dark dress
pants a beret and a pair of street shoes
was he coming from fancy diving someone
grabbed a pair of scissors and cut his
pants at the knees so he would be able
to run easier what does anyone doing
okay great the two South Africans were
barefoot the starting pistol is fired at
3:30 p.m.
so nobody talks to anybody before an
event doesn't seem literally nothing
nothing happens if you're there great if
you're not whatever get on the lines get
on the line the dust was immediately a
problem mostly because all of the
traffic right this is on a dirt road and
it was a busy dirt road so while they
were running had to watch out for
crosstown traffic too
every truck strange trakula functioning
road yeah well you don't need to shut it
down no why would you shut it down
course not this was aware this was years
after most of our laws were created yes
yeah things had been established life
had started cars with runners coaches
and their doctors would drive alongside
the runners kicking up tons of dust was
hitchhiking legal could you just could
you marty mcfly it had to have happened
the runners stop frequently to COFF
lures pulled ahead quickly and then
Thomas Hicks took the lead from him it
didn't take long for the first runner to
go down with him Garcia collapsed on the
side of the road he was rushed to the
hospital where it was discovered he was
hemorrhaging from inhaling the dust what
this thing should have been held in a
hospital I so far support all of this if
any of us had to organize the Olympics
this is not far off from what we would
do the dust had coated his esophagus and
ripped his stomach lining casualty of
war continue I've changed my opinion on
this entire lesson if he had not been
brought to the hospital within an hour
he would have died well the next to go
down was Josh look I love it someone in
the front was just like she just heard
about dust ripping a stomach open I was
like good I care more about smog now
than ever before
Jame what's the cedar bucket doing still
trying to track that C story it's become
animated by this cuz nobody noticed it
was a bucket look at it on the beam it's
just right up there there's a balance
balance perfection perfection simple
perfection next good I was
Lordan also overcome by dust he started
vomiting and decided he'd haven't had
enough of this [ __ ] race where did
he get not far he didn't even get ten I
love people getting less than a hundred
yards like what the [ __ ] are we doing
yeah you're starting to be like maybe
can we make it nine miles I mean how can
we just do that nobody leaves open the
truck with you all right great we'll put
the ribbon okay great you're gonna enjoy
this story it was just around this time
that one of the South African runners
Len toe was chased off the course by a
pack of wild dogs so how is this a row
what it road is this there's the weird
thing is if you go back a hundred years
somehow they would run this better than
ya do it a hundred years later a wild I
love that all these Peck days was just
like well there goes that one a new
sport just broke out wild dog run away
chase those dogs don't run the Filipino
you'll ruin the event now even when
there was proper OTT like you could have
solved that problem just move the
Filipino town near that wild dogs
alright guys it's obviously who can get
there the fastest it's 24 miles there's
no pack of wild dogs I can kill you also
any houses you pass they are legally
allowed to shoot you as you run here we
go he ran a full mile off course before
the dogs finally gave up that's good you
know what miles gold right there he
should have won
yeah it's right through the dog attack
it's really any marathon I'll tell you
that's hard to overcome absolutely yes
meanwhile the Cuban ran along in his
street shoes and dress shirt
he kept stopping and chatting with
spectators in broken English loving it
yeah didn't even notice the dog thing at
one point he was running and stopped
next to a car because he saw the
passengers were eating peaches he asked
if he could have won and they said no so
he did what anyone would do and just
grabbed them and ran off wait sir this
is this guy knows how to do a marathon
if you're gonna run him dusty marathon
this is how you do you did wear a beret
and hock peaches now one of the reasons
he grabbed the peaches was he had not
eaten for two days before starting the
race we did lose all his money yeah
anybody had a belly full of dust now he
barely got there to even running the
ridiculous race but the peaches were
just his first run-in with fruit later
on he came across an apple orchard and
enjoyed himself some apples they can
only assume he ate them off the ground
because they turn out to be rotten
this led to horrible stomach cramps
which caused him to lay down and then he
fell asleep also still in first place I
also like picturing that the truck of
peaches had like thousands of page like
they could easily go like now no peaches
for you fancy runner so this guy is the
he misses dogs he doesn't get dust gut
yeah but he puts himself on IR by eating
rotten apples yeah yeah and not even
really doesn't really damage him he just
gets tired and his tummy hurts and he
takes a sleeping should we wake him up
and told him he won the gold leap leader
at this point was Sam allure but then he
started having terrible cramps as well
this may have been because they weren't
allowed
to really drink anything they can only
get water to stops one at six miles and
another at 12 miles
Jesus this was because James Sullivan
thought that this marathon would be good
time to study the effects of purposeful
dehydration wait he's here I have some
ideas for tomorrow's race James we need
to give them water for the last goddamn
time you would have been able to had I
not tipped over all the buckets earlier
dammit
even the cedar and I seem to James James
it's how I breathe oh my god I love that
no one has told him to kind of stay away
from the games at all well they all said
like a six-month audition where was like
well he's terrible well I can't wait to
see what he does with the real Olympic
yeah yeah yeah listen let's let's let
him see it through I think he's got a
lot of experience under his belt so it
minimizes the amount of fluid people can
take in the runners were not allowed to
get water themselves at the two
designated points of course not only
someone who had nothing to do with the
race could give it to them right so even
their coaches and doctors couldn't sure
so Sam alar started walking and then
pretty quickly just stopped altogether
and sat down he was done imagine one of
the runners just like taking a shortcut
into town hi would anyone be willing to
come with me back to the main road and
pour water into a cup and then handing
it to me
it was like
Oh psycho how about these peaches please
I'm I'm so dehydrated I'm competing in
the I'm about to win a gold medal if
someone could just give me a couple
what's a gold medal I don't even know
anymore I'll be honest
lores was also getting cramps this is
around mild nine he was currently in
fourth place he gave up also and asked
for a ride from a car passing by he
hopped on board
and he waved at people along the route
and his fellows runners as he rode past
meanwhile Hicks was in the lead that's a
[ __ ] you wave Yeah right that's not so
Hicks is in the lead he was actually one
of the favourites to win the race but at
the 10 mile mark he needed help too he
had a couple of guys there to give him
support and he was begging them for
water but they wouldn't give me because
they couldn't what a horrible rule I
don't know it seems pretty cool you're
right but what they could do under the
rules was sponge the inside of his mouth
with warm distilled water you know the
rules are maybe getting a little too
squeezed all of the runners will be
equipped with the sponge James James
James James they're allowed to dippity
just set up areas where they can have
water may no vinegar no James yes
laughing what is it the 17 mile mark
Hicks's crew gave him a cocktail of
strychnine and white eggs or egg whites
sorry egg whites then that's not true
whites who wouldn't want egg whites when
they were dehydrated with a mouthful of
dust in 90 degree wetter weather just
and a little tiny bit of poison what
what what why is why strychnine is a rat
poison but it also stimulates the
nervous
system and so is used as a stimulant at
the time in very small doses remember
rocky I got to the second word of that
song I realized I made a horrible
calculation at this time there were no
rules about drug use in the Olympics so
why would there be now promoted yeah
lures car that he was riding in broke
down at the 20 mile 21 mile mark and his
cramps has stopped so he just got out of
the car and started running again
couldn't be happier with that decision
he quickly ran past Hicks who was
leading loser
one of lorises one of Laura's support
crew told him to get off the course but
he passed on that advice and kept
running he was the first one into the
stadium and he crossed the finish line
in just a hair under three hours the
crowd went wild they started chanting an
American one yeah the daughter of
President Teddy Roosevelt was there and
she was about to put a wreath on his
head that when an angry Olympic
officials realized what was going on
Loras had never said he'd won the race
and had been acting like it was a joke
the whole time now the crowd started
booing lors
hmm lawyers copped to it and said it was
all a joke he wasn't actually going to
accept come on and and people weren't
actually amused and the officials
disqualified him now back in the actual
race Hicks was still in the lead when
Loras had passed him his crew told them
to keep going because Loras was
definitely going to be disqualified
Hicks was ashen and limping from the
poison he took so they don't even know
the right amount of poison to give him
well you at this point when he think any
poison is not good some poison is good a
little bit actually there is so when
you're dehydrated it's probably not
great no I listen I've been anti
strychnine the whole story you don't
need to tell me yeah but you didn't hear
mixed with egg whites come on yes
it is fun like it with a little spinach
what that is egg whites and strychnine
all right give it to me yeah I want to
run word had reached him that lures had
one so he was slowly just chugging along
sad but then someone told them that
lures had been disqualified he started
moving and pushing his legs to run his
support group even more egg whites and
strychnine and this time mirandy Oh get
a protein DUP drunken poisoned they
soaked him in water and that appeared to
do the trick he looked alert again and
his pace quickened they soaked him in
water
yeah they just dumped water over well
that sounds illegal it's good to know
that drugs have always been a part of
the Olympic Games a race official later
wrote over the last two miles of the
road Hicks was running mechanically like
a well-oiled piece of machinery his eyes
were dull lustreless the ashen color of
his face and skin had deepened his arms
appeared as weights well tied down he
could scarcely lift his legs while his
knees were stiff then he started
hallucinating it's the Olympics I just
had a idea of rubber soles of my feet
would make it so much easier well he
thought he had another twenty miles to
run so he started begging his support
crew for food and then he wanted to lay
down but they wouldn't let him knowing
if he stopped it was over they offered
him tea but he passed on it they gave
him more brandy yeah they were you're
way out there were two small hills
before the stadium he walked up and then
jogged down the other side by the time
he got into this stadium he could no
longer run he was barely shuffling along
his support crew picked him up and they
held him like like like he was like a
bench like they made a bench with their
hands the finish line so his feet were
dangling so it looked like he was
running
sorry they're just so desperate for
someone to actually win yes if that's
okay what I like is that he made it all
the way to the stadium and only then
were they willing to do something that
could possibly disqualify it make a
bench with your hands let's swing him
into the air put your taint on my palm
there we go connect palms anyway so it
looked like he was running so he was
declared the winner
three hours 28 minutes and 53 seconds
this is the longest official finishing
time an Olympic marathon history Tuesday
ferry was tripping his balls
he lost eight pounds during the marathon
the marathon more egg whites were needed
huh he never ran another marathon why
interesting had he taken one more dose
of strychnine he would have died might
have been the best thing for him up to
32 racers who entered 18 did not finish
the Cuban Felix carbajal with a coffee
stand even with his nap and Street shoes
finished fourth what took a nap finished
foremost medal yeah the guy who was
chased a mile by dog oh come on
finished ninth and his fellow countryman
finished 12th Wow
I love that he didn't even gather the
dogs didn't even throw it just like a
moral that I really just want to do it
for me you know I mean Sullivan was
pissed at lures and gave him a lifetime
ban by the Amateur Athletic Union a few
months later after I went to calm down
Laura's got the ban rescinded on the
grounds that he was temporarily insane
and unknown prankster history I'll brake
of people tells me there's a president
it's not his first prank which makes me
think there's a history of pranking and
that this prank Wow outlandish is very
funny and prank or terminology he just
pulled a hell of a break you don't like
to play by the rules
slippers very funny guy the next year
you won the Boston Marathon with a car
right all right how about a happy ending
remember George I sir the gymnast with
one leg
of course he performed in the story
alive
he performed in this second gymnastics
competition on October 29th and one day
he won six medals three of which were
gold Wow
one of those was for the horse vault
which at the time did not use a
springboard so just call the big buddy
company then he's up he won that yep
no one attempted to compete in the
Olympics with one artificial leg again
until 2008 the World's Fair / Louisiana
Purchase celebration / / / racism Museum
/ bull it officially came to a close on
2fm December 1st 1904 when it was dumb
it's like you just got out of war oh
thank god
I think st. Louis is still recovering
from this event there's still I got it's
still we still have we think how we
think about 1904 was bad for us it was a
good time so the fair was considered a
huge success 19 19 million people came
to the fair but to be fair that's over 7
months still that's a lot of people
right that many people didn't even exist
back then are you sure about that I
don't know any history this is the only
history I'll ever retain yeah two years
two years after the Olympics in 1906
serious after the Olympics in 1906 the
IOC reviewed the Germans protest of the
fancy timing event I love that they
won't let it go sausage you know like
why was it even taken seriously to begin
with
the resolve was fanciest we must solve
this the result was overturned there's
no video third place was declared a tie
how could they there's no way the
Germans weren't fancier when you put it
like that I mean what yeah what did a
German what's the first word that comes
to your mind
fatty diving diving always there right
now that I think that is their legacy
that and that alone to this day the
United States has not acknowledged the
decision and we're Rick's about our fake
right before the credits that's the like
thing that comes up to this day the
United States who owned it was like what
a dramatic story about these divers that
I didn't care about it off to this day
the United States still won't
acknowledge their success directed by
the next Olympics were held in London
right you know eight and they followed
the 1904 pattern of Americans being
[ __ ] in the opening ceremony the US
flag bearer refused to dip the flag for
King Edward the seventh and of course
there was a marathon strychnine was used
again a runner from Italy entered the
final lap of the marathon in the stadium
but was such a mess he collapsed twice
and then started running the wrong way
well is it a cute do you have to go the
same way the whole time I think that's a
fair question for marathoners for novice
marathons weird what is a rule in what
is in a rule John 84.8 total I feel like
wins it even if that's just in a circle
at the beginning yeah yes
Dominic not go ahead judges turned him
around and point him in the right
direction and because of that he was
disqualified so an American one
Sullivan continued to be a very
influential person in early Olympic
movement even though IOC president
Pierre Cooper Tom hated Sullivan he
never really got in with the old boys of
the IOC he didn't have their respect but
he could push his agenda because of his
power in the US during the National
Games Sullivan got himself the position
of secretary of the US Olympic Committee
he felt it would be great back home to
be seen helping Americans as much as
possible so he lodged endless protests
at all the events average averaging a
few per day while the sensational press
loved it actual journalists thought he
was a total [ __ ] for the 1912 Olympic
Summer Olympics female divers and
swimmers were finally allowed to compete
America have very good female swimmer
named Ida schnell but Sullivan sticking
to his being a piece of garbage didn't
allow the American women to participate
Sullivan finally died September 16th
1914 at Mount Sinai Hospital and after
an operation on his intestines which is
now an Olympic event and now his great
great grandson is running for president
Bernie write Bernie Sanders Bernie
Sanders Bernard everybody feel good
about America yeah well that's a normal
story its way people were way dumber
than you even thought like you're like
no way it really did like that it's a
good story to hear because it makes you
sort of look at our time right now and
be like it's not that bad
yeah we've come we've come a long way we
hear Verdi maybe we don't have wild
really Ferguson right now you mean feels
like I'm in the stadium and I'm about to
run backwards so I'll just put you're
tainted by hey I'll get you there Jeremy
I carry my taint so even then as they
were doing it as it got serious I can
run then fine let us hold your tainted
eggs move your lemon Hicks round like
you're running like a road me feel weird
keep doing it the strychnine is kicking
in I mean that is just that is
absolutely that's insanity dave has a
hat what's up girl
as that is the wackiest it's
legitimately wacky it's a wacky are you
willing to go on record with that yes
Wow Olympic that's thing someone has
learned what the dollop is what's that
are you guys having a hat off yeah
where's your suit I are you competing in
hats law I already I already won already
one right all my hats have been given to
me and I pride myself on that I've never
purchased one hat that should be an
event
ladies ladies and gentlemen we have to
get going we've probably gone way over
and and other comics have to come up
here and do shows and get sick from the
mic that I've been talking into is it
weird that I still think curling
shouldn't be he's doing sweeping the ice
oh my God look at these Filipinos trying
to curl dogs look out dogs you guys
thank you very much